einen Tag nur das teuerste bestellen wir
haben das vor einiger Zeit gemacht habe
ich am Handy überall das teuerste bei
den liefer Apps bestellt ihr habt das
Video übrigens gefeiert mir macht es
auch sehr viel Spaß genauso wie aber
auch das günstigste zu bestellen weil
auf diese Art und Weisen findet man
immer wieder neue Inspiration neue
Sachen die man sonst wahrscheinlich
nicht bestellen würde und heute machen
wir das ganze in Restaurants wir begeben
uns zu drei verschiedenen Restaurants
mit unterschiedlichen Preisklassen und
gucken was wir uns bieten können wir
einfach das teuerste Leben günstig wird
heute wahrscheinlich nicht aber ich
glaube auch dass wir sehr leckeres Essen
genießen dürfen deshalb reden wir nicht
lange herum und bewegen uns zum ersten
Spot beginnen wir mit dem Frühstück da
bin ich mal wieder bei einem sehr
bekannten Laden in Köln gelandet und
zwar bei Kaffee Burg ich meine viele von
euch kennen es auch wenn sie nicht aus
Köln kommen wahrscheinlich das
bekannteste Frühstückslokal in
Deutschland und der ein oder andere
sagte auch mal das ist ein bisschen
teuer deshalb perfekte Location für
heute wir gucken was das teuerste auf
der Karte ist und wir bestellen einfach
los geht's
[Musik]
ich habe wirklich das Gefühl wir haben
den ruhigsten Tag seit langem hier
erlebt weil ich fahre auch häufig vorbei
ich wohne nicht weit von hier und es ist
immer eine Riesenschlange wir haben
gerade einen ruhigen Moment erwischt ich
glaube das ist auf jeden Fall gut für
uns gehen wir einmal die Karte glaube
ich muss mich ein bisschen durchklicken
und das teuerste zu finden Crispy
Chicken Bauern 16,90 €, ist schon fünf
Stück in der höheren Preisregion ja es
könnte wirklich das teuerste sein Bauern
sind natürlich auch geil ne ich glaube
so kaffeegetricks die Leute so ein
bisschen aus indem sie eigentlich zum
Frühstück etwas essen was kein
traditionelles Frühstück ist ich sehe
hier auch Mac and cheese more fahren
aber guck mal wie wunderschön das aber
auch wirklich gemacht ist ne wenn es
auch so ankommt schauen wir mal
Topseller ich glaube tatsächlich ist
werden diese gedämpften nicht dass man
wirklich gerechnet hätte als gesagt hat
dass jetzt frühstücken gehe ich bin
gespannt das klingt sehr interessant
gerade zum Frühstück zum Bauern gucken
wir mal wie es aussieht
gönnt euch also der Crispy Chicken ist
dann absoluter Favorit geil ich danke
dir Bro ich sagte ehrlich das ist 16,90
€ Wert absolut sieht so aus aber es ist
halt wirklich viel Geld ne im Vergleich
mit du gehst in Wege holen so beim
Kaffee um die Ecke ne das heißt ein
dritte aber der Geschmack wird es
entscheidend für sowas ne das kriegst du
halt nirgendwo anders und da ist das
dann auch wieder rechtfertigt wenn es
jetzt einfach gewesen mit Trüffel drüber
wenn nicht so schön aber das die
verdammt wild aus wir haben hier so
gedämpfte Bauerns die auch wirklich
schön so sind muss ich sagen hier drin
einmal pulp beef oben drauf Sesam dann
noch ein bisschen roten Coleslaw sieht
wirklich gut aus und hier drüben
mariniert in ordentlich Soße spicy
chicken auch wieder das Bauern auch
wieder groß lockig schnappe immer so ein
Bauern und das ist wirklich ein
ordentliches Ding das ist nicht
Frühstück das ist Brunch also Frühstück
und Mittagessen auf einmal
kalorientechnisch wahrscheinlich auch
aber gehen wir mal rein hier
richtig schöne süße butterweich so ein
bisschen fast schon wie so ein Gulasch
so im Mund so das ist das zerfällt
einfach so und wahrscheinlich auch eine
Rinderbrust dieser Code schon schön
mariniert schön saftig
ist auch normal oder dabei eine Ansage
ich finde die Portionsgröße irgendwie
sehr krass das ist so für zwei Personen
ich probiere ich bin gespannt
ich habe nichts gehört du ja gut
jetzt habe ich was gehört schöne
klebrige süß-saure Marinade bisschen
Barbecue wenig Schärfe bisschen zu viel
für mich aber zum Frühstück so ein
paniertes frittiertes chicken Code in so
einer dicken ja auch richtig geil und
ich sage euch ehrlich auch wenn ein paar
hier drin steht
16,90 € dafür zu zahlen wenn das ankommt
Preis leistungsmäßig top das kriegst du
nirgendwo anders quality ist super und
die Portion ist riesig deshalb gucken
wir mal was uns als nächstes erwartet
nach diesem Frühstück ist es Zeit für
den nächsten Sport wir ein bisschen
gechillt keine Sorge wir sind vor einem
libanesischen Restaurant verlassen
Orient und ich sage euch ehrlich sehr
gerne hin aber eigentlich nicht wenn ich
viel Geld ausgeben will denn es ist eher
niedrigpreisiges Restaurant es gibt
verlassen es gibt jawama aber es gibt
auch Teller Gerichte und ihr seht hier
vorne schon vielleicht 35 € Kino Teller
ich habe keine Ahnung was mich erwartet
oder warum der kinoteller heißt wir
gehen rein und bestellen das Ding
[Musik]
das ist eine ordentliche Portion für wie
viel Personen ist das zwei Leute drei
Leute normalerweise
wow leute guckt euch das mal bitte an
das ist wirklich sowieso eine
obstschüssel also ein gigantischer
Teller und da muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen 35 € auch mehr gerechtfertigt und
ich heute Abend noch mal von satt also
können wir beide unseren Freunden was
mitbringen die freuen sich unfassbar
schön angerichtet auch ne innen drin
haben wir ein bisschen Hummus oben drauf
diesen ich glaube dass dieser
Granatapfelsirup die ein oder andere
frittierte speise ich glaube das hier
ist Käse Halloumi reisen wir testen uns
mal komplett durch und geben vor allem
unsere Meinung ab für 35 € jetzt schon
fair ich möchte als allererst machen
geil knusprig außen schön fluffig ne
trotzdem schmeckt frisch auch alles ne
hier haben wir wirklich mehr als man auf
den ersten Blick sieht wir haben
Karottensalat wir haben normalen Salat
wir haben gegrilltes Gemüse Hähnchen
schabama dann haben wir diese
frühlingsrollene artigen Dinger ich
glaube da stand draußen brautfänger ne
sieht richtig geil aus mit Hackfleisch
gefüllt
man kann so richtig schön kombinieren so
man nimmt von allem was ich sage euch
echt mit drei sehr hungrigen Jungs oder
wir beide mit Freundinnen sind wir damit
seit wir stellen uns in die Mitte hier
mit Freunden hin Hammer also der heißt
ja Kino Teller so richtig gut vorstellen
dass so bei einem geilen Film das
nächste nebenbei diese Platte das habe
ich schon probieren die scharfe Soße
guck mir mal die Schafe Soße ist
ganz bitte zu gehen jetzt entwickelt
sich so langsam so eine Schärfe hinten
raus schon Schaf doch probier mal so
eine hier sieht aus wie Spinat auf jeden
Fall kann aber auch Petersilie sein
ausgefallene Geschmäcker drin schmeckt
direkt orientalisch trotzdem knusprig
hammer
geil
Alter
geil gewürzt
absolute Empfehlung nicht so eine Bock
auf
Deutsch sehr sehr lecker
an einen guten Tag
doch das ist für eine Familie
wie sollen wir danach noch mal was essen
nach dem Frühstück wir essen erstmal
auch eine geben wir euch unseren
ich glaube man kann sagen dass wir den
Kampf verloren haben würdest du immer
noch sein lassen alleine essen kannst
nein ich glaube nämlich
packen wir das ganze ein Lebens mit nach
Hause
und ich sag dir ehrlich mit fünf
Personen easy fertig 35 €. jeder kommt
auch seit seinem Geschmack richtig geil
jetzt brauche und ihr merkt vielleicht
ist ein bisschen später wir haben
einfach vergessen das Abendessen zu
drehen aber kein Problem auch heute
bestelle ich gerne noch mal das teuerste
von der Karte wir sind wieder auf der
Aachener Straße und die Adresse fürs
Abendessen heißt Balthasar eines meiner
persönlichen Lieblingsrestaurants wenn
ich einfach so rausgehe was esse was
trinke aber ein Problem gibt es die sind
ziemlich teuer und das teuerste auf der
Karte wird extrem teuer sein deshalb
haben wir uns einfach mal umgehen wir
rein und bestellen uns was leckeres
Essen
[Musik]
ich weiß von ungefähr wo ich gucken muss
ich meine ich war schon häufiger hier
aber damit das ist ganz verwolf war
schon Grill gegrilltes Gemüse Drillinge
Sauce Ruinen keine Ahnung was das ist 38
60 es gibt hier manche Sachen die
wirklich absolute Klassiker sind die
Spaghetti aglio olio auf Carpaccio super
gut aber es gibt eine Abteilung der
Karte die ist auf jeden Fall besonders
und zwar Alter saß Fleischerei das ist
nämlich im Prinzip sogar ein richtiges
Steakhaus hier und da sind natürlich die
Sachen die wirklich ein bisschen teurer
sind
oh
Chateaubriand von Black Angus Premium
Rinderfilet 600 g Garzeit 40 bis 50
Minuten 96 Euro also ihr hört vielleicht
dass es hinter der Kamera nicht lacht
der mittlerweile ist der Kamera eric ist
gerade im Urlaub habe ich ihr wisst es
ein bisschen Zeit vergangen zwischen dem
Drehs aber normalerweise würde jetzt
extrem laut lachen das klingt dann
ungefähr so
ich denke wir müssen es verstellen das
Problem ist nur die 40 50 Minuten aber
ist dann halt so ne Romy hast du das
auch was das für eine Frage okay dann
bestellen wir uns noch eins zwei Seiten
dazu und lassen uns gut gehen unser
Essen ist angekommen und um ehrlich zu
sein das ist ein Festmahl wir haben hier
das chateaubrior das ist schon echt
ordentlich also natürlich ist das für
zwei Personen dementsprechend ne wenn
man es runterbricht was ist eigentlich
die Hälfte aber es ist das teuerste auf
der Karte deshalb haben wir es bestellt
dazu so friends Preis so zum Dippen
perfekt mit einer Trüffel Mario dann
haben wir chimichuri gedrückt für das
kartoffelgerät und ein bisschen Gemüse
ne muss natürlich auch sein ich probiere
erstmal die Preis
sehr sehr nice wäre das was ich mir auch
so bestellt hätte nein ich Bock gehabt
hätte der mir super gutes flank Steak
und ich persönlich mag sich mehr als von
Rinder weil das ist einfach so mehr
Charakter hat mehr Geschmack hat
probieren wir uns einmal komplett durch
ich nehme hier mal so einen Rinderfilet
Weg schneidet sich wirklich wie Butter
wir wurden natürlich nach dem
gewünschten Garten gefragt Medium und
ich probiere
das ist man nicht alle Tage also auch
ich nicht ne auch mit gut Videos aber so
ein Chateaubriand das ist wirklich
Endstufe hier auch eine sehr üppige
Portion gekrüppeltes Kartoffelpüree die
Beilage sind extra bei den 97 Euro also
es ist wirklich auch grundsätzlich aber
ein teures Restaurant aber es ist auch
sehr gut geil cremig schöne trüffelnote
paar Stückchen drin verbesser noch mal
extra Butter drin Muskatnuss Leute
ich würde sagen wir verdrücken das ganze
dann sehen wir uns gleich noch mal
abschließen
[Musik]
was soll ich sagen wir haben zu zweit
130 € bezahlt also 65 € pro Person Essen
und Trinken das ist unfassbar viel Geld
also für einmal essen gehen crazy mal
ich glaube nicht an Steaks essen gehen
so wirklich also ihr habt gesehen das
hatte schon ordentlichen grauen Rand in
der mit also das ist einfach nicht smart
so das ist meistens Steak muss es scharf
anbraten danach auf kerntemperaturgaren
und dann ruhen lassen das dauert einfach
viel zu lange für mich dass es in dem
Restaurant Sinn macht außer man hat er
zu wie die Steaks irgendwie im Wasserbad
ich glaube mein persönlicher Favorit
heute war wirklich verlassen Orient wir
haben so viel für unser Geld bekommen
Alter sei Liebig wahrscheinlich mit der
beste Service in ganz Köln aber wir
haben gemerkt das teuerste ist nicht
automatisch immer das Beste vielen Dank
fürs zuschauen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Video wieder macht's gut und
bis dahin